Oh as half of simon and garfunkel he
dominated the pop chart scoring hits
like Sicilian homeward bound the group's
number one records included bookends and
of course bridge over troubled water
after the duo split in 1970 carful
Garfunkel rather moved on to a
successful solo career he and Simon were
inducted into the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame in 1990 and they later received the
Grammy Lifetime Achievement Award his
new memoir is called what is it all but
luminous love that word notes from an
underground man Art Garfunkel
good morning okay because your voice
will talk about your voice in just a
second but you were telling us before
the break something we all thought was
very interesting thirty years it took
you and you never plan to write a book
no I carry a notebook in the back pocket
with you now not right now but you carry
notebook and you with that notebook you
do what well I walk across countries
I've walked the United States and I've
walked across Europe and I as I walk
little insights occurred to me some of
them are big and I get a notion of a
first line and I go that line has rhythm
and it means something to me it touches
the theme I've thought about all my life
so between that first line which is like
a good song first line and the theme
which is where I know I'm going I just
spend the next 24 hours fixing and
twirling my hair and and erasing it's
your voice though that I think just
really captivates people it's been said
that it's made grown men cry you call it
your secret joy your print your private
joy your secret gift you know at an
early age that you had something special
in your throat well I sang in synagogues
at 5:00 I knew I could sing I would play
with my Spalding in the alleyway in
Queens and I would sing to myself and I
heard a lovely thing and I felt this is
God's gift to me it created gave me a
spirituality connected to singing right
from the earliest age so you share it
with others as a Jewish boy I would sing
in the temple the temple had a big high
ceiling with lovely wood wall so the
reverb
was wonderful and and that became a big
thing for me the echo which puts tails
on your notes and extends them I was
entranced with that sound did you have
confidence you could do it solo
after you impulse lit yeah I didn't have
confidence that the world would accept
me but I knew I could sing without Paul
ship with you and Paul because in the
book it sounds very contentious it
sounds very low yeah I would say it's
intense it's like a marriage it has
summers and winters it waxes and wanes
it is best not talked about you leave it
alone sometimes you get a call from Paul
or I from him and out of nowhere
something funny goes on and you laugh
and you go I miss him and then you have
a dinner there's a lot of pressure to
come back together for something I don't
call it pressure there's a lot of
curiosity its standard to be asked do
you think you'll work together and I've
always said who knows life isn't life as
a surprise we don't know what comes next
nowadays I say no we won't no this book
is not sort of a traditional member as
you said I mean it's it's kind of a
travelogue and as you note it's a diary
of sorts books you've read poems all
sorts of different things and that what
is all but luminous it's a beautiful
title it's as if you're walking and you
are so entranced by the beauty of
everything you tear up and in the blurry
vision of tearing up what is it all but
luminous it's a poet's notion or points
out it's not your typical thing you talk
about records that have changed her life
the Beatles here there and everywhere
Beach Boys Good Vibrations but then you
said Scarborough Fair well I gave my
well because it's but it's songs that
changed your life when we did
Scarborough Fair I thought it just came
out lovely and these things are new to
the world and they're new to your own
ears first you know I heard Simon and
Garfunkel before the world did I mean I
made them yeah so Scarborough Fair felt
to me like the best most flowing most
organic thing we ever recorded where
would you put bridge over troubled
water top 5 top 3 when I think of bridge
I think of the production now I'm the
producer of our records I go into the
control room and I'm mix and balance the
music and the backing the
instrumentation and I'm very proud and
pleased with how bridge over troubled
water was constructed the way the last
verse lifts off and so what's the third
it's very fair and then there's bridge
over troubled water what's third Cecilia
is pretty happy people love it the
infectious quality of Cecilia belongs up
there yeah it's always breaking my heart
yeah
Art Garfunkel what a pleasure to have
you here thank you lovely to be here
thank you what is all but luminous is
out today